era una velada agradable una especie de
fiesta de los vecinos los residentes de
este Barrio Obrero de Baltimore se
habían reunido como todos los años pero
esta vez se convirtió en una pesadilla
hacia la medianoche hora local sonaron
disparos y la policía fue alertada dos
jóvenes resultaron muertos una mujer de
18 años y un hombre de 20
Poco después de las 12:30 a.m los
oficiales recibieron múltiples llamadas
sobre un tiroteo su llegada los agentes
encontraron a varias víctimas que
sufrían heridas de bala una mujer adulta
murió en el lugar 29 víctimas fueron
trasladadas a hospitales de la zona
Baltimore es tristemente celebre por su
violencia la ciudad tiene una de las
tasas de homicidio más alta del país
pero anoche se trataba de una simple
fiesta de Barrio y a los residentes les
cuesta entender en un intento por frenar
La ola de violencia en su ciudad el
nuevo alcalde ha hecho de la lucha
contra la proliferación de armas de
fuego una de sus principales prioridades
en su opinión este último tiroteo
demuestra una vez más la necesidad de
controlar Estas armas
quiero reiterar que se trata de una
tragedia absoluta que no tenía por qué
ocurrir pone de manifiesto una vez más
el impacto y la necesidad de atajar la
proliferación de armas ilegales en
nuestras calles y la capacidad de
quienes no deberían tenerlas para
hacerse con ellas
en Estados Unidos más de 40.000 personas
murieron por armas de fuego en 2022